you said
nations in relation to each other are is
essentially in a state of anarchism yeah
well Anarchy basically means the
opposite of hierarchy sometimes people
think when you're talking about Anarchy
you're talking about murder and mayham
but that's not what Anarchy means in the
realist context Anarchy simply means
that you don't have hierarchy there's no
higher authority that above States
states are like pool balls on a table
right and in an anarchic world uh
there's no higher authority that you can
turn to uh if you get into trouble and
of course the political philosopher who
laid this all out was Thomas Hobbs and
Hobbs talked about life in the state of
nature and in the state of nature you
have
individuals and those individuals
compete with each other for power and
the reason that they do is because in
the state of nature by definition you
have no higher authority and hobbs' view
is that the way to get out of this
terrible situation where individuals are
competing with each other and even
killing each other is to create a state
it's what he calls the Leviathan and
that of course is the title of his
famous book so the idea is to escape
Anarchy you create a state and that
means you go from Anarchy to hierarchy
the problem in international politics is
that there is no world State there is no
hierarchy and if you have no hierarchy
and you're in an anarchic system you
have no choice but to try to maximize
your relative power to make sure you are
as we used to say when I was a kid on
New York City playgrounds the biggest
and baddest dude on the block not
because you necessarily want to beat up
on other kids or on other states but
because again that's the best way to
survive and as I like to point out to
people the best example of what happens
when you're weak in international
politics is what the Chinese call the
century of national humiliation uh from
the late 1840s to the late 1940s the
Chinese were remarkably weak and the
great powers in the system upon them and
uh that sends a very important message
to not only the Chinese but to other
states in the system don't be weak be as
powerful as you can and we'll talk about
it but humiliation can lead to
resentment and resentment leads to uh
something you've also studied which is
Nazi Germany in the
1930s we'll talk about it um but staying
to the psychology and philosophy
picture what's the connection between
the will to power in the individual as
you mentioned and the will to power in a
nation the will to power in an
individual has a lot to do with
individual's psychology uh the story
that I tell about the pursuit of power
is a structural argument it's an
argument that says when you are in a
particular structure when you're in a
system that has a specific
architecture which is anarchy the state
have no choice but to compete for power
uh so structure is really driving the
story here Will To Power has a lot more
to do with an
individual uh in in the nichan story
where that concept comes from so it's
very important to understand that I'm
not arguing that states are inherently
aggressive right my point is that as
long as states are in in Anarchy right
they have no choice but to behave in an
aggressive fashion but if you went to a
hierarchic system uh there's no reason
for those states to worry about the
balance of power because if they get
into trouble there is a higher authority
that they can turn to there is in effect
the
Leviathan
I